fait leur entrée à tanger eut demandé ça
il ya quelques années tu t'es tu t'es
battu avec quelqu'un un peu comme avec
pascal praud il est là ça t'embête de le
voir on veut très sympa je m'en fous tu
vas dû serrer la main ben ça dépend qui
sait michaël youn je suis pas mal
je deux géants lancé l'appel je tiens
d'abord c'est parce que
c'est quoi l'histoire c'était
c'était sûr c'était sur skyrock marrant
sûr que bernard se souvient même pas on
fait doit peut-être même pas se souvenir
lors c'est moi je vois tu deviens pas si
messi veut dire regarde ça tu reviens
pas je toujours que si bernard était
invité pour parler de l'excellent site
internet de son fils des ans
et il y avait un auditeur qui lui a posé
une question sur sur le match benfica
marseille à l'époque où il y avait la
main de vata tu étais sorti du match en
disant je me suis fait avoir une fois
voilà une fois tu recommences tu vois le
buteur n'a pas dit exactement la phrase
que vous aviez dit à l'époque voilà
l'auditeur a dit vous avez vous pouvez
maintenant comment vont faire voilà et
donc rien à voir avec ce que j'ai dit
elle conte alors l'auditeur dit si vous
avez 10 à bernard bernard dit non je
n'ai pas dit ça le devient ça non et je
dis bon ok on va couper la poire en deux
bernard de toute façon que vous l'ayez
dit ou pas vous avez fait 8 mois de
prison c'est quand même pas pour rien
c'est ça que je fais et c'est là que
vous êtes énervé un peu quoi c'était un
peu une phrase de petit con mais ça
m'arrive serait paraît-il
donc bernard jette son casque ouais on
était en différé bernard 715,6 dit quoi
je viens en ami on pose des questions à
la con comme ça il va dans le bureau du
directeur et dit non je suis pas
d'accord comment ça se fait qu'on traite
comme ça et moi je vais le voir un petit
peu désolé je dis bon c'est ce qu'on va
faire berner comme on n'est pas en
direct on va rien enregistré la fin et
c'est là que vous m'avez dit non on va
par et ont jusqu'à la fin ce qu'on va
faire c'est que je vais te casser la
gueule
et
là et là bernard avec c'est très très
belle palucher ces très grosses paluches
mam est une bonne petite claque dans la
gueule à une claque et moi je suis
séparée david le lien s'est par ailleurs
le il accompagne vient le mouvement et à
ce moment là mon directeur d'antenne m'a
demandé de présenter mes excuses que
j'ai refusé de faire et défaire et de
fun était fâché non mais tu vois parfois
il ya des choses qui t'énerve parce que
le mec il peut te prendre en défaut
entre citant une de tes phrases il faut
que tu acceptes mais pas qui tire une
phrase que t'as pas dit oui mais
pourquoi pourquoi une claque à l'époque
fut annoncée parce que le but était pas
pris parce que tu vois mal un oui c'est
vrai faire le malin tu avais envie de te
faire pousser et puis en plus je suis
passionné la question tu l'avais pas
fait poser exprès non et voilà et c'est
là que vous avez tort parce qu'il y en a
des mecs qui font ça tu sais que d'un
art nippon passagers ont passé des
textos en va des écrans rendent pas tu
vois ça existe les mains qui font des
phrases qui n'existe pas ou qui
reçoivent des sms qu'ils en ont jamais
parce qu'à l'époque à l'époque on
comprend que jamais un sport il y avait
un sport casser du tapis voilà c'est que
le mec c'est à celui qui arrive est le
mieux à la marelle alors il n'y en a pas
beaucoup mais c'est vrai qu'à une
analyse sur toi choix des bons comme je
dire allez ça va aller mais lorsque tu
vas faire tu vas lire son livre ah oui
la nappe
librement ses billets
mesdames messieurs et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu